this all started because I was talking
to another young liberal lady and I made
the claim that when you have sex with
somebody you are consenting to the
possibility of pregnancy and you found
this very objectionable no no that that
was you agree with that no yeah I do
agree that you're consenting to the
possibility of pregnancy but you said um
you're consenting to the possibility of
pregnancy and she agreed and you said
well if it's consent to the possibility
then it is consent to pregnancy that's I
took the issue with cuz I don't believe
in any other scenario do we hold the
concept of consenting to an action means
that you're consenting to every feasible
outcome of that action but but the
possibility of pregnancy the the only
end of that is pregnancy I'm not saying
the possibility of pregnancy or this or
that or some other thing saying the
possibility that this action will result
in a pregnancy would I I don't I don't
understand what the distinction would be
what do you mean only end of that the
just the term possibility means that
something could happen so there's
multiple possible outcomes of sex right
so one thing that I like to pull from is
not just the pregnancy aspect cuz again
I mentioned to you in one of our videos
going back and forth that humans have
sex for multiple reasons and you took a
little issue because you said well
there's supposed to only be one reason
but no no there are multiple reasons but
there but some reasons are more
important than others yeah and I would
say that um especially if we're looking
at what sex is naturally ordered to Sure
producing Offspring is one of them but
also communication relationship bonding
those are all very critical things that
also take part in a relationship you can
even have sex with the person and not
further that relationship there are
various things that you that take place
well you you'll further some sort of
relationship you'll further a
relationship but that if you want to do
hookups or if you wanted to do like a
one night stand or whatever it could
take place but you don't need to
furtherly engage with that person so
that now what if you have the hookup or
the one night stand and maybe you're
even using artificial contraception but
doesn't work or it breaks and the girl
gets pregnant well then you're not going
to have anything to do with her that
relationship's not going to go any
further well no I think you could have
nothing to do with somebody regardless
of whether or not they get pregnant you
but I'm asking in this specific Cas in
this specific instance then it depends
on what the two people want if you guys
like each other enough you want to stay
together I'm not saying that you
necessarily need to be like kick them to
the curve I don't even know where that
necessarily comes from but again sex has
multiple different possibilities it
could be that someone gets pregnant
after that point it could you want still
further the relationship you could say
you don't want to further the
relationship that's not necessarily what
the point is the point is but if you
don't further the relationship then you
would be abandoning your child and the
the woman that you've you've left I'm
going to take issue with that a little
bit because I feel like you are there's
this concept of an intuition pump right
so if we use the term child intuition
pump an intuition pump yeah so
essentially it's when you push loaded
emotional connotations into words that
don't necessarily need them in a given
scenario so for example if you're to say
a child right me and you aren't dumb
when we colloquially use the term child
we're refer we're referring to birthed
people people who are already born no I
I I refer to offspring yeah Offspring I
mean see I can understand why you can
use the term Offspring right because you
are still referring to offspring when
you say the word child but if I say
child or kid or even baby those all
three things are connotated of people
who are born and those are actually
definitions I don't think so I mean when
for instance when my wife first became
pregnant with our first child when when
before the baby was born people would
ask oh how's the baby doing I would
think about my future son my my child
I'd get the bedroom ready we'd start
buying clothing so I I certainly when
when I would refer to my child I would
be referring to the baby in the womb you
do you know why you were referring to it
as a child because it's my child yeah I
mean yeah but also under the you were
under the impression that that child was
going to be born correct when people ask
how's the baby doing and and that also
works the other way because a lot of
times you can say it's impolite to ask
necessarily if you don't know someone's
pregnant you don't want to call someone
fat yeah you don't want to call someone
fat but you also don't want to assume
that like either everything is just
peachy or that they want to keep that
pregnancy well I want to assume that
someone is not going to murder her child
I I do make well that you're factually
wrong on that because murder is a
specific legal definition you could say
it should be murder but if you're going
to assume that they're going to murder
their child that is assuming that the
killing is unlawful and that's also
assuming that abortion is it is unlawful
because it's it is not moral law maybe
but not law law I I don't know what I
don't know what law you're talking about
which abortion is the natural law and
the moral law from which we derive the
civil and you mean natural law and moral
law I mean laws that are true for all
people at all times so we have certain
civil laws and positive laws you know uh
the state of Louisiana might have a
different kind of traffic law than the
state of New York but there are certain
laws like um it is wrong to commit
murder that are true for all people at
all
times and so the way that we get our
civil law and our positive law is in
part by uh deducing certain conclusions
from the moral and natural yeah but
you're also shoehorning in the legal
term while trying to Define why it's
wrong for like everybody murder murder
has been understood to be wrong since
yeah no what I mean by that is that the
term murder is the unlawful killing of a
person right but if someone kills
somebody in self-defense that's not an
unlawful killing it's still killing yeah
it wouldn't be murdered right so you
can't say that necessarily like oh it is
murder when it isn't because the killing
in this instance the termination of the
pregnancy which would entail the death
of the fetus is lawful so it's not an no
no it's notw oh because you believe that
it shouldn't be lawful or you believe we
have a difference of of opinion here you
say that it is it is lawful that's the
fact that's the reality opinion though
that's a fact that's not even an opinion
it is lawful what do you think an
opinion is opinion is something that's
subjective up to your interpretation on
the books the law is that abortion is
not murder so if you say abortion is
murder you are factually incorrect so
before we get back to abortion for a
second I think you're mistaken about the
meaning of the word opinion because you
seem to be conflating an opinion with a
preference do you do you understand the
distinction between the two there is a
distinction between the two but that's
not the connotation which I was using
well you were saying an opinion is
subjective right in the way that a
preference is subjective you know I like
vanilla more than chocolate that would
be a preference that's not what an
opinion is an opinion is when you make a
statement of fact from your perspective
so here's how I would show you an
example well that gets into the whole
like alternative fact realm you don't
you can make a a proclamation about what
you perceive the world around you to be
and that can be your opinion but there's
a specific distinction between opinion
and a fact now you can say that like uh
a preference and an opinion are similar
in that they're both subjective but that
doesn't mean that necessarily they are
the same thing they're not both
subjective because a preference can't be
wrong whereas an opinion can be wrong so
for instance I can say I think that the
moon is made of green cheese it is my
opinion that the moon is made of green
cheese that is my opinion but it's wrong
I could also say that uh I think the sun
is shining outside today and that would
also be my opinion but it would be
correct so some opinions can be correct
and some can be why because they're
statements of fact from your perspective
no some opinions can be some opinions
can be correct and some opinions can be
wrong because of the underlying data and
the underlying evidence that is to the
reality to which they refer so you can
say that it is your opinion that the sun
is shining and that's also an opinion
that is based off of the fact that the
sun gives off light but you could also
say it's my opinion that it's made out
of that the moon is made out of cheese
but there's literally no evidence to
back that up so I think reducing it yeah
I think reducing it down to a preference
versus an opinion is kind of trying to
misc conscrew the words there no no
because I I could have a preference you
know I could say I like cigars which I
do and you don't like cigars and that's
my preference and that's your preference
m
neither of those is wrong they're just
our tastes
and as we say but I could say a cigar is
made of tobacco and you could say a
cigar is made of green cheese and I
would be right and you would be wrong
but that's not a statement of fact from
your perspective that's what is that's
what you believe to be a fact which is
what an
opinion so you can't say that is a
statement so I have a preference of what
type of cigar whatever those two things
cannot be wrong but if you're saying an
opinion is really a statement of fact
from your perspective that's what you
just said that's what you believe to be
a fact it's not a fact so that's what
I'm saying if you get into this realm
where it's like a fact is entirely
dependent on what you perceive it is
that inherently means that one person
cannot have a wrong opinion but you said
that one person can have a wrong opinion
it's not that the the fact relies upon
my perception it's that my perception
can accurately or inaccurately uh
describe the fact so I I could say this
is a glass of
Seltzer I think this is a glass of
Seltzer it is not a glass of Seltzer
because it is my opinion that it is it
is my opinion that it is a glass of
Selzer because it actually is in fact
but if you said this is a glass of
chocolate milk and it is my opinion that
this is a glass of chocolate milk your
opinion would be incorrect and your
perception would be defective no I will
say I think that the the way the
language is getting parsed here it's
like an opinion is a statement of what
is a perceived fact from your
perspective but it's not a statement of
fact from your cuz you see where
distinction is you can't say that it's a
statement of fact from your perspective
it's a declaration you're saying I think
this I think X but in reality the truth
is actually y so if you're saying oh
it's a yeah but if you're saying it's a
statement of fact from my perspective if
I say I think X you it's a fact that you
think X but that's the as far as it can
go it's not really a fact from your
perspective I feel like the reason why
I'm making the distinction here is
because it's kind of like putting my
subjective like opinion on the same
level as like cuz it's like oh you can't
say that I'm wrong cuz it's a fact from
my perspective that's kind of maybe I'm
reading into what you're saying wrong
but that's kind of the vibe I get I get
the alternative fact Vibe where it's
like I'm not sure what vibe that is
that's the that's the that's the you
know trumpist Vibe the thing that I'm
getting where it's like you can see
people in a crowd and like well it's my
opinion that I had the biggest
inauguration size of all time and that's
just an alternative fact because it's
from my
perspective digital audience he actually
did but that's a topic for another
digital audience is crazy I don't think
Obama was pulling too much on the live
stream forums in 2008 he probably wasn't
yeah exactly that's why that's why that
such a statement would be true too but
but uh I I guess the reason it's
important to clear this up is because we
have a disagreement here over whether a
baby in the womb is a baby is morally
significant in the way that you and I
are morally significant and we have a
disagreement you say I think that well
no actually what you're saying is it is
simply a fact that the baby's not a baby
and I'm saying it is my opinion that the
baby is a
baby opinion but but at most one of us
is going to be right no my statement of
fact was that abortion wasn't murder
because legal term that would presuppose
that the baby is not a baby if the baby
is a baby then abortion would be murder
right because you'd be you'd be
unlawfully killing a person well no
because again when you say the word
unlawfully you're talking about your
moral like your moral La no I'm I'm
speaking of the objective moral La yeah
and the law in the United States is that
abortion is not murder if they overruled
it and said yes now abortion is murder
then it
can't say is murder because it's
unlawfully king aaby or or whatever it
is lawful in many states abortion is
substantially or entirely illegal
according to even the Civil positive
yeah so at at the best you can have it
is kind of sometimes murder depending on
the state you're you you don't have
caveats in that statement you say it is
murder I guess the I think the mistake
that you're making though is that you're
suggesting that the positive law or the
civil law of the state is the ultimate
law law I'm sorry but I'm sorry also the
laws in those states do not rule AB
abortion as murder they'll usually put a
really short time frame that's like
almost impossible for the women to know
that they're pregnant and if you still
have the abortion you still are aborting
that zygote that is unique human DNA but
they don't consider it murder I think
taking it to murder is the Draconian
position where it's like okay well now
we need we need to prosecute as if it
was murder but even Republican states
don't do that no that's not true and
including in liberal states if for
instance though New York just changed it
because they wanted to liberalize
abortion but if you were to murder a
pregnant woman you would be charged with
double
murder because you've killed the mother
and you've killed the child and that's
true even in Liberal stat yeah that is
true and I think rational I think the
rationale behind that that's not saying
the same thing as abortion the process
of terminating a pregnancy is murder
because the reason why murder terminates
the pregnancy yeah no the rationale is
because there is no distinguish you
can't predict whether or not a woman is
going to to bring a pregnancy to term so
if you have a pregnant woman and you
kill think it from a legal sense if you
have a pregnant woman and I kill you and
then I kill the woman and then the baby
dies too whatever I get charged double
because we don't know what was going to
happen we're under the impression that
they were going to bring the pregnancy
to term because you it wouldn't really
make sense to prosecute otherwise but
you're not the murderer would not be
charged with murdering the woman and
violating her right to decide whether or
not she wanted to take a pregnancy to
term charged with is double murder the
reason they're charged with double
murder is because when you kill the
mother or whatever so that's what I'm
saying abortion is a separate concept
chared no because abortion is abortion
is the ability to terminate a pregnancy
right so if you're killing somebody
terminate a pregnancy well you're using
if it's an ectopic pregnancy then the
baby's already dead but the how did we
get to how did we get to the topic of
ectopic pregnancy because the procedure
is still in the bo I think is you're
kind of moving away from homicide no no
hold on hold on because I think you're
because the the point how am I moving
away when you cut me off and then I'm
trying to explain you why what you just
said was wrong what I'm saying is an
ectopic pregnancy you would still get
rid of that pregnancy via abortion the
term abortion is just the termination of
a pregnancy a lot of times it does
result in the and it's the termination
of a nonviable pregnancy in particular
of an abortion refers to the termination
of a nonviable pregnancy how what
percent what percentage of abortions do
you think are uh in the case of ectopic
pregnancy or a threat to the life of the
mother oh that's a different question
I'm because what I'm saying is the
reason why far more than 99% of
abortions are elective where the where
the baby is viable yeah no no what you
don't understand is the concept of
viability 80% of abortions take place in
the first week not the first week the
first you're bable of living outside of
the mother's yes that's what I'm saying
that's why so the vast majority of the
time and the but the baby would still be
viable in as much as the baby would
continue to develop and live just like
you that's not again you're mincing
words because that's not what the term
viability mean you're saying that it's
you're saying it's not euphemisms it's
literal words I don't know what eism
maybe I'm what do you eism means yeah I
know what euphemism means I'm not using
one but the thing is tell euphemism is a
word to try to paper over a harsh
reality with language that would be less
evocative and clear which is why I'm
referring to a human being in the womb
and you're trying to refer to say a
pregnancy or the product hold on did I
wait hold on hold on I didn't say that
the pregnancy or the the fetus isn't a
human being it is but I'm telling you
okay good I'm telling you but then why
won't you call it a human being what I
said a pregnancy I
the reason why I say because I'm
describing what the term abortion refers
to it's referring to ending a pregnancy
meaning it doesn't necessarily mean
killing a human being if the human being
is already dead you'd use the same
procedure but abortion abortion doesn't
operate on people who are already dead
abortion you you could ECT that's why
I'm bringing up ectopic pregnancy the
threat of an ectopic pregnancy is the
baby is continuing to grow and threatens
the life of the mother no but no that so
if if it's like develops cancer if like
the the cells that are developing into
the baby turn cancerous or there's
something where well the mother could
develop cancer separately which would be
yeah no but I'm saying in terms like
that where the the baby is dead or you
have like a miscarriage or something
like that the process on the process by
which you terminate that pregnancy is
still abortion abortion is simply
referring to terminating a pregnancy of
an unviable fetus which means or a
nonviable fetus which means that in the
time in which it is terminated it cannot
survive outside the mother that's the
term abortion now you can say abortion
could be used for killing a baby or
everything but that doesn't change the
but it doesn't change the fact that
there are circumstances which the baby's
already dead and that procedure is still
called an abortion so outlawing that
procedure it isn't though it is you use
the word terminate what does the word
terminate mean end a pregnancy okay and
what is a pregn what do you mean by a
pregnancy the fetus is inside of the
mother and so if so the termination of a
viable threat what do you mean when you
say you're going to end the pregnancy by
which you say you mean the fetus that is
inside of the mother but well I don't
mean ending the fetus that is inside the
mother I mean ending the process of
pregnancy and what is that process the
process is the continued growth of that
pregnancy which is which is life yes
even if the baby is no longer growing or
something that's still a pregnancy
because it's still inside the mother the
termination of a viable pregnancy is
delivery or C-section so I don't think
you understand so the termination of a
nonviable pregnancy would be when the
baby cannot live outside the mother
right and you get an abortion whatever
that's how you or if there that's not an
ectopic pregnancy that could be just any
time before the baby could live outside
of the mother yeah you're okay so we're
no longer talking about ectopic
pregnancy we're yeah no I was never only
I was never only like trying to make the
point that ectopic pregnancy is the only
I'm saying the term abortion refers to
terminating a pregnancy that can be at
any stage of the pregnancy if you
terminate a nonviable pregnancy that is
abortion that is usually what will
happen in the first like few weeks or
the first trimester of uh which is when
most abortions happen when you terminate
a viable fetus meaning a fetus that can
live outside the womb unless it's like
threat to the mother which is very rare
that is a delivery if the pregnancy ends
on a viable fetus that is usually
because the mother has pushed out the
baby or got a C-section you don't like
me using this term baby or person or
human being you don't like because I
think because I think that you and me
and everyone watching knows that the
image that pops into mind when you say a
baby or a child we say the term how's
the baby how's your baby to a woman
who's pregnant because we're under the
assumption that they going to bring that
baby to term we why yes we make that
jump that it's like you're going to get
perhaps that's how you interpret it the
way I interpret it the reason that I
would ask how is the baby doing is
because I'm uh inquiring into how that
baby at that particular moment is doing
that's why that's why I use that
language yeah no that's the same those
two things but I'm not saying because
the baby will those two things aren't
mutually exclusive you could actually
not mutually you could be inquiring into
the condition of the baby but the reason
why you're using the term baby is
because when you see someone who's
pregnant you're not you don't think
about hey do they want to bring this to
do they want to bring this to term
what's going on in their personal life
youum you see their pregnant that means
they're going to have a baby that's this
brings us back to the point that's at at
hand here because what you seem to be
suggesting here is that the identity of
the being inside the womb is contingent
upon whether or not the mother wants to
have an abortion so if the mother does
want to have an abortion let me at least
explain what I think you're saying and
then you can correct me if I'm wrong
you're saying if the mother wants to
have an abortion and get rid of the baby
then you wouldn't refer to it as a baby
you wouldn't ask how's the baby doing
obviously but if the mother wants to
bring the baby to term and then raise
the baby and send the baby off to
college then you would ask how is the
baby doing and the and the question of
whether or not that baby is a baby
depends upon the wishes of the mother as
pertains to that baby is that what
you're saying well no so what I'm saying
is the language that you use right so
when we're using the term baby you don't
there's no point in which you're growing
up through childhood and you stop and
think huh let me comp let me consider
the complex Natures of pregnancy and way
the mother you just kind of assume you
see someone showing they're going to
have a baby how's the baby doing and
most times it's not offensive because
usually if you're getting to the point
where you're showing you're probably
going to already carry the baby to term
but when we're talking about the fact
that the vast majority of abortions
happen within the first trimester a lot
of times you're not even showing now or
you know drugs yeah and at that point
you don't even really get the
opportunity to ask how's the baby doing
because a lot of times you don't even
know that somebody is pregnant or they
don't even know that they're pregnant
and then they get the thing so it's like
when you see somebody who is obviously
pregnant a lot of times they're further
along they're planning for a baby so we
make that jump hey how's the baby doing
because you under the assumption that
yeah most people going to bring the baby
to but if that baby okay so if the baby
is a baby and you're going to call if
you asked somebody hey how's the baby
doing then you'd listen to them and if
they're like well I we're going through
some stuff and I don't know I might I'm
looking into getting an abortion if they
get that close to you I don't know I
don't really that information like
something close to me but if you got
they got close to you and they're like
yeah I don't know um you'd probably be
better off if you didn't like oh but
your child how's your child doing put
the child because you know what that's
invoking sure okay so let's leave it at
baby if you're granting that you see a
pregnant woman you say hey hey that's a
baby I'm acknowledging that that thing
is a baby then don't you necessarily
have to conclude that it would be wrong
to kill that baby through abortion cuz
you're saying it's a baby well I'm yeah
if you use that language but you just
said you would use that language no I'm
saying yeah if you're saying oh how's
the baby doing and they're like yeah I'm
going to kill this baby no I'm just opin
yeah but I'm saying assuming you support
legal so you get yeah you get two
separate like things right so if you say
oh how's your how's the baby doing and
they're like oh I'm I'm planning on
murdering this baby that's one thing if
you're saying oh how's the baby doing
it's like well I don't really know I
think I'm I'm going through some stuff
with the pregnancy my doctors told me
that XYZ is going to happen or I'm just
not in a position right now I think I'm
going to add my pregnancy that's going
to be fine because most humans can
understand it's like okay this person
doesn't have the this person doesn't
have the I didn't say I didn't say Oh I
thought you said funny no I wouldn't
find that fine at all why wouldn't you
find that fine well because we both just
agreed that whatever it is that is
inside the mother's womb is a baby we
both agreed that we would you just said
baby but fetus means no I'm saying you
using baby the reason why we Al use the
term baby is because we make the
assumption that they're going to give
birth to that baby it's a lot of times
when we see someone pregnant if they're
obviously showing that they're pregnant
they're probably far long enough to
where you can make the Assumption
they're going to give birth but if I was
a medical professional or if I'm talking
about the concept of pregnancy or a term
relating to that pregnancy like abortion
I'd use the term fetus because we're
talking in scientific terms now there is
no room for not talking about oh what
value are we going to assign to this kit
we need to give the give the mother like
a time to actually decide what's going
to happen What does what does the word
fetus mean what does the word fetus mean
it's a stage of human development do you
know the meaning of the word though I
don't know like what are you talking
it's a Latin yeah Oh I thought you okay
I don't know like the Latin Origins it
means offspring